[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs bienvenue
à cette onzième saison dans leur quête
on est très heureuse de vous retrouver
bon soir isabelle soir marie monde on
commence ce soir histoire de pénélope ô
pénélope c'est une femme qui se bat
devant les tribunaux mais aussi devant
son église
les témoins de jéhovah
j'avais parle et me coucher sur les
limes déshabiller la journaliste pascale
turbide et le réalisateur yannick
lapointe ont confronté les membres
influents de la communauté pour pénélope
sa quête pour la justice est devenue un
véritable combat tu parles c'est que tu
es la fin moustache de ce lundi
[Musique]
c'était un homme charmant
un homme qui paraissait quand même bien
toujours un bon souvenir toujours une
parole douce
c'était la nuit le faisait noir donc
médias j'ai jamais été dans ce chemin et
l'eau et arrêter la voiture et c'est à
ce moment l'autre me demander est ce que
tu me trouves pas ce qui me demander si
je retrouvais bout après me mentais
embrasse moi
et il m'a demandé si j'avais déjà
embrassé quelqu'un soutenant qu'un geste
du salon j'ai reculé puis est rentré sa
langue dans ma bouche je me suis dégagé
de lui puis celle qui m'a dit tant
paraissent vraiment pas content de
savoir ce qui se passait et me dit tu es
une grande fille mène son père serait
pas content tu te sois si sur moi sa vie
qu'elle a je devais avoir 11 1 11 ans et
j'ai trouvé ça dégueulasse
elles étaient deux mais une seule des
petites filles va s'en tirer
l'histoire de l'autre commence à mont
laurier
[Musique]
quand j'étais plus jeune je pensais que
tout le monde faisait ça dans la
communication qui je cherchais
maintenant à savoir qui faisait quoi
avec qui je pensais que chacun aurait
avait avec quoi maîtresse enfin où je
sais pas trop s'exciter la normalité
il s'appelait michel courtemanche
c'était l'ami de la famille le père de
trois enfants
le premier a complimenté pénélope et le
premier dit elle à la toucher je devais
avoir 11 ans ça fait elle veut pas tout
à fait tort était sur mes genoux puisse
emmener me reconduire chez nous puis
mais lundi que je t'ai b il me caressait
encore la poitrine je veux vraiment mal
figé j'ai regardé ça fait comme si je
suis triste et grave devant elle puis me
dis c'est pas grave à parle pas
[Musique]
toutes les semaines michel courtemanche
et son épouse enseigne les principes de
la bible à de futurs témoins de jéhovah
pénélope garde de leurs enfants
c'est la routine du lundi et puis quand
y revenir de 2 sets et sur deux lots il
envoyait sa femme soit allé chercher du
restaurant ou louer un film puis
venaient m'agresser dans la chambre je
refusais toujours de mettre la main sur
son pénis et de prendre soeur son pénis
dans la bouche toujours
elle a 14 ans lors de la première
relation sexuelle complète
ce sera la première d'une longue série
qu'elle aurait subis et ce même si sa
famille a déménagé à 4h de mont laurier
et venaient visiter mes parrains pour
dire bonjour qui resté pour la nuit à
coucher et ses nuits là il ne me
rejoindre dans ma chambre est là on
parle de viol complet des inuits
[Musique]
pénélope ne sait pas qu'elle peut dire
non c'est en parcourant un article du
magazine des témoins de jéhovah qu elle
le réalise
je les lui et j'ai compris que ce que je
vivais ça lève le mot cela vient le nom
à l'époque geste ait fait en la calle
venue garder les enfants et essayer de
rentrer ses mains en dessous de mon slip
c'est là que j'ai pris ses mains puis
que j'ai dit savoir faire c'est terminé
presque tout de suite elle révèle son
secret ses parents sont atterrés et en
bons témoins de jéhovah il alerte les
dirigeants de leur congrégation
leur but faire exclure michel
courtemanche des témoins est ce que
michel courtemanche a été exclu à cette
époque là non et est-ce que vous avez
été exclu oui j'ai été exclu pour quelle
raison parce que j'avais un job j'étais
pas mariés pour que michel courtemanche
puisse être expulsé lui aussi il aurait
au moins fallu un témoin oculaire ou une
autre plaignante
c'est obligatoire dans le système de
justice interne des témoins de jéhovah
ce qui est aussi obligatoire c'est de
recueillir la version de la victime
alléguée ce que personne n'aurait fait
mes questions c'était pourquoi vous
n'avez jamais voulu savoir ce qui
m'était arrivé comme vous m'avez jamais
questionné puis pourquoi vous avez rien
y faire qu'est ce qui a été fait c'est
une bonne question à poser aux témoins
de jéhovah mais aussi à la sûreté
municipale de mont laurier
car pénélope s'est tourné vers la police
en 1995 il a fallu que je parte avec mon
petit courage elle et rencontre un
policier que je connais c'est pour qui
finalement qui était pas formés non plus
à me recevoir
c'est le patrouilleur jean-pierre
gaudemer qui l'accueille au poste belge
qui est l ultime atout fin va vite et
via les débats les sept vins étrangers
j'étais pas si à l'aise que ça puis
c'est sûr que
j'ai pas tout raconter voici ce qui
reste du dossier de police outre la
déclaration de pénélope
il ne contient rien le policier n'a
rencontré aucun témoin potentiel dans la
famille ou la congrégation de pénélope
c'était mieux ce que la région c'est
quand même yann yeux se ferment puis
quoi que ce soit c'est correct pour
regarder s'il ya le saut dans le milieu
là dessus il n'a peut-être pas tout à
fait tort des témoins de jéhovah ne
dénonce une possible agression d'enfants
que si la loi les y oblige
ce tableau réalisé par les témoins eux
même exposé toutes les étapes de leur
système de justice religieuse
quant au chemin vers la justice laïque
il est pour le moins tortueux jusqu'à 13
étapes avant d'alerter les autorités et
jusqu'à 30 étapes à franchir avant de
fournir des documents à la justice
mais le but ultime c'est s'arrêter à
l'étape 24 et de maintenir le secret je
regarde ça et il ya quelque chose qui me
vient à l'esprit la maison des fous
c'est incroyable comment une victime
peut passer à travers
autant d'étapes pour à la fin très
souvent avoir aucune reconnaissance de
ce qui s'est passé
marilou lagacé a grandi chez les témoins
avant de quitter de son plein gré depuis
elle tente de comprendre et de
déconstruire leur justice parallèle
quand on étudie le processus
on réalise vraiment que si tu es c'est
plutôt un processus d'évitement c'est
plutôt un système de protection de la
réputation des témoins de jéhovah
protéger la réputation des témoins de
jéhovah c'est exactement ce que les
témoins de mont-laurier aurait demandé
aux parents de pénélope
il y a 20 ans quand ils ont appelé mes
parents nous ont mis la pression pour
qu'ils essayent de me décourager mais
dissuader il voulait que je retire ma
plainte
je voulais que mes parents me convaincre
que je te pour salir la réputation des
témoins de jéhovah mais penelope
persiste et en novembre 96
le procès de michel courtemanche débute
à mont laurier
je t'aide seul seul sur le sol mais
j'étais seul aussi parce que les témoins
de jéhovah avait interdit à tout le
monde est allé
selon nos informations lors du procès
michel courtemanche j'aurais insisté sur
le fait que pénélope avec 14 ans l'âge
du consentement à l'époque il a toujours
nié avoir eu des relations sexuelles
complètes avec elle pénélope n'a ni
témoin ni preuve des agressions qui
seraient survenus avant et après 14 ans
d'après moi
à cette époque là oui j'avais fait tout
ce que j'avais pu avec les moyens que
j'avais le plus de connaissances que
j'avais j'avais fait tout ce que je
pouvais
le 19 décembre 1996 michel courtemanche
est déclaré non coupable il ne reste
aucune trace des motifs du jugement ni
les témoignages lors du procès
[Musique]
au début des années 80 avant l'histoire
de pénélope michel courtemanche habite à
mont laurier
mais il travaille à terrebonne la
semaine tu m'as rappel on a vu une
grosse télévision en bois d'un salon et
michel et arsenal dans les boys en avant
ils gardent parfois les enfants de son
patron un soir il demande à carole
poudrier dix ans de s'asseoir près de
lui il se serait mis à la chatouiller et
à la caresser
elle s'enfuit dans sa chambre et c'est
là qu'il a rejoint il s'est accroupi
timothy ces poudres apporte utilise
parce que ton pari serait pas content
c'est pas pire en d'une grande fille
maintenant qu'ils seraient pas contents
que ce soit c'est sur moi mais je dis je
le dirai pas elle tient parole
quelques mois plus tard michel
courtemanche lui aurait demandé de
l'embrasser une première fois puis une
seconde je peux pas croire que sa salive
sa langue avait rentré dans ma bouche et
j'étais j'ai eu un dégoût tellement
total que gg je me suis dégagé de lui je
me servirai barjac
cette fois-ci carole parlera à une amie
plus vieille qui fera son devoir de
témoins de jéhovah et dénoncera michel
courtemanche aux dirigeants la semaine
suivante un ancien de la congrégation se
présente à la maison familiale
j'étais vraiment stressé de parler d'une
sorte de sexualité avec un monsieur que
je connais pas devant mon père mon dieu
c'est un gène à m'aimer
il m'a demandé ce qui s'était passé
alors je lui ai dit et il me remercier
me dit qu'ils étaient pour s'occuper de
ça cet ancien selon carole c'est john
mchugh wayne qui a depuis gravi les
échelons jusqu'au quartier général des
témoins à toronto dans une lettre que
nous avons obtenus john mchugh wayne
admet connaître carole et sa famille
mais il nous avoir discuté avec eux des
gestes reprochés à michel courtemanche
voyons d'autres c'est impossible c'est
un film mais pas chez moi dans mon
sous-sol avec mon père et par là mon
père j'étais là j'étais assis à terre
aux autres et à 6 sur 10 20 je m'entends
au après tout était correct ne peut pas
dire qu'il ne pourra compris
le père de carole poudrier ou confirme
avoir discuté du cas de michel
courtemanche avec les anciens de
terrebonne il dit avoir pardonné à son
employé qui a continué de travailler
pour lui un certain temps
est il possible que les témoins de
terrebonne n'ait pas averti leurs frères
de mont-laurier de la présence d'un
agresseur potentiel dans leurs
congrégations impossible et ça jamais
très ma main au feu surtout pour quelque
chose comme ce nom c'est impossible
la première chose qu'ils doivent faire
c'est on prend le téléphone on appelle
sa création en lisant ton membre de ta
coriace on y est chez nous puis voici ce
qu'il fait depuis presque 40 ans toutes
les politiques des témoins disent la
même chose dans une situation comme
celle là une congrégation doit en
avertir une autre des allégations de
péché grave commis par ses membres
puisque me choque hautement je faisais
pas partie de la congrégation terrebonne
c'est sûr qu'ils ont avisé la
congrégation mont laurier
parce que c'est une patate chaude à
terrebonne qui n'a pas fait sa part dans
son ciel les adultes les adultes les
anciens parce que dans l'organisation
des témoins de jéhovah ya jamais un seul
homme qui est au courant
[Musique]
si l'information sur michel courtemanche
a été transmise aux anciens de mont
laurier
les parents de cette congrégation ne
l'ont jamais su c'était en 1983
environ un an avant que ne débute
l'histoire de penne là
[Musique]
pascal moralement c'est évident mais
légalement est ce que les témoins de
jéhovah ont l'obligation de dénoncer à
la police des allégations d'abus sexuels
probablement qu'à cette époque là c'est
être pas tout à fait clair encore mais
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de doute
possible dans la loi de la protection de
la jeunesse
il faut dénoncer vous moi les témoins de
jéhovah tout le monde doit dénoncer un
abus sexuel ou un abus physiques
s'il ya un motif raisonnable ça c'est
pour la protection de l'enfance en ce
qui concerne la police s'est pas tout à
fait la même chose dans ce très
différent parce que contrairement à ce
que tout le monde pense
on n'est jamais obligé de dénoncer un
crime en fait l'exception c'est quand il
ya un crime qu'ils aient commis sur un
enfant si un professionnel constate
qu'un enfant est victime d'un crime lui
il est obligé de dénoncer et là il ya
des ententes entre les différents
organismes
pascal après la pause la suite de votre
enquête oui et je pense que c'est là
qu'on va comprendre que l' enquête
interne des témoins de jéhovah a n'a pas
été fait avec énormément de sérieux
[Musique]
ce qui m'est arrivé à 12 ans va toucher
au sein faire dessus mon chandail dans
sa voiture raisin il vient me rejoindre
les amants brasse mais son pénis dans la
bouche
l'histoire de ville et la baie est très
particulière parce que à toutes les fois
qu'il essaye de faire un cheminement à
cétacés toujours fermé ce fait fermé la
porte
j'avais eu le dernier mot je n'avais pas
pu m'expliquer comme fo devant des
bonnes personnes compétentes
ça devient difficile de se débattre de
se défendre de toute façon on n'apprend
pas à se défendre chez les témoins de
jéhovah on apprend à tourner et l'autre
joue pour recevoir leur claque en 2014
pénélope fait une rencontre déterminante
avec l'ex témoins marilou lagacé elle
décide de relancer les protagonistes de
son histoire par lettre qu'il a envoyée
aux cinq anciens qui m'ont exclu à
l'époque et je les envoyer au siège
social est à mon agresseur je voulais
dire que c'était terminé que j'aimais je
me tairai
c'est une première étape et cette fois
ci les anciens réagissent rapidement le
vendredi soir j'avais deux anciens qui
m'appelait pour me dire qu'ils avaient
bien reçu ma lettre mais qui comprenait
pas ma question c'est quoi votre
question mais question c'est est
pourquoi vous n'avez jamais voulu savoir
ce qui m'était arrivé ils m'ont dit on
n'a pas besoin
on n'a pas eu besoin de s'en occuper
georges leclercq est allé te rencontrer
chez vous pour prendre la déposition
georges leclercq était président de la
congrégation de mont laurier il y avait
cinq ans lorsque pénélope a révélé son
secret et qu'est-ce que vous avez réagi
binger duc ce n'était jamais arrivé et
j'aime est venu me rencontrer les
parents de pénélope le confirme georges
leclercq n'a jamais recueilli leur
version ni celle de leur fille
mais là j'ai s'impliquer vraiment il y
avait quelque chose qui était encore
plus grave plus l'os est quelque chose
qui soude qu'il fallait que je comprends
absolument je me suis dit oh si c'était
pour protéger son ami
c'est à qui son ami son ennemi c'était
mon agresseur michel courtin michel
courtemanche
georges leclercq était effectivement un
des meilleurs amis de michel
courtemanche
il dirigeait la congrégation dans les
années 80 la période où penelope aurait
été abusée à mont laurier et carole
poudrier à terrebonne les deux par
michel courtemanche
il est exclu il rêve d'être réprimandé
après ces actes à moi et ils résultent
exclu après les actes de pénurie
mais courtemanche n'a pas été exclue des
témoins de jéhovah à l'époque
pourquoi l'ex-dirigeant georges leclercq
refuse de répondre aux questions
[Musique]
en 2015 pénélope veut des réponses car
depuis longtemps des bruits courent
elles ne seraient ni la seule ni la
première que courtemanche aurait touché
mais elle ne connaît pas carole poudrier
qui de son côté ignorent l'existence
même de pénélope
jusqu'au jour où carroll raconte son
histoire à une vieille amie qui connaît
bien mont laurier
quand on m'a dit que ça soit ravi terme
ont leurs yeux jeudi en réussite si je
connais quelqu'un qui est qu'ils
savaient déjà essayé sur moi à l'époque
il me gardais pia vais essayer de de
m'embrasser puis de me toucher
et je lui ai nommé le nom michel
courtemanche le soir même la confidente
de carole répète le nom michel
courtemanche a sa propre copine une
certaine marie lou lagacé vous pouvez
vous imaginer ma réaction
cette soirée là j'apprends qu'il ya une
autre victime kevin et là je connais
l'âge de quarante poudrier je connais
large de pénélope et là je comprends que
bien que carole s'est fait agresser
avant pénélope et j'écris à pénélope ce
soir là est-ce que tu connais une carole
poudrier mais c'était surréaliste
j'aurais même pas cru que ça ce que ça
aurait pu arriver je recevais les textos
et indirects du restaurant où elle était
et puis j'en revenais pas c'était
c'était un cadeau elle s'était enfin
trouvé et c'est chez carole qu'elles ont
pu comparer tous cas me racontait je
voyais des les mêmes paroles
joyet le même personnage va ressembler
relate l'histoire beaucoup mais en même
temps ça ressemblait pas à votre choix
elle a eu la brillante idée de leur
poussée
elle était forte
c'est ça qui fait la différence j'ai vu
une femme de mon âge mais j'ai vu une
petite fille aussi ça m'a vraiment
faibles ça me fait beaucoup de peine
poule on était 2 maintenant on était le
témoin l'un de l'autre
carole est devenu ma vérité supprimé et
là on a compris que les autorités
religieuses savaient
pour carole puisqu'elle en a parlé puis
elle a rencontré des anciens mais en
fait on a compris que leur processus à
ce moment là avait effectivement protégé
un pédophile
ce qui est certain c'est que vingt ans
auparavant ni la police ni le procureur
et encore moins le juge du procès de
michel courtemanche ne connaissait
l'existence d'une première victime
potentielle
carole poudrier aurait-elle pu faire
pencher la balance du procès en faveur
de pénélope le sicom pose une question
ensemble dollars la juge à la retraite
céline lamontagne a examiné pour nous
les récits des deux victimes alors donc
de ce que j'ai lu du dossier les faits
similaires première mais l'aja victimes
la nature des gestes sexuels poser les
baisers la fal l'évolution des
accouchements dans les deux cas c'était
similaires ensuite il y avait les
paroles qui ont été prononcées qui sont
importants qui sont les mêmes paroles
ont été prononcées exactement dans l'est
dans les deux cas la juge lamontagne ne
souhaite pas refaire le procès et elle
rappelle qu'une preuve de faits
similaires n'est pas toujours admis en
cours mais lorsqu'elle est admise
elle peut théoriquement faire une
différence c'est sûr que la preuve des
faits similaires
admise vient ajouter du poids à
l'inversion de la première victime
et ça rend plus probant le fait que oui
c'est pour ces quelque chose oui est-ce
que je suis convaincu hors de tout doute
raisonnable
mais j'ai une preuve 1 et 2 c'est une
évaluation que la justice n'a pas pu
faire dans ce cas ci les témoins de
jéhovah n'ayant jamais révélé à la
police
l'existence d'une première victime si le
juge lui avait demandé d'expliquer ce
que vous avez subi lorsque vous aviez
dix ans au moment du procès
l'auriez-vous fait à 100%
100 % après avoir envoyé sa lettre en
pénélope est prête pour la seconde étape
la rencontre avec de hauts placés des
témoins de jéhovah qu'elle décide
d'enregistrer
elle a beaucoup de questions
ils ont peu de réponses jusqu'à ce que
pénélope demande des nouvelles de
georges leclercq
l'ancien dirigeant de la congrégation de
mont laurier la réponse des anciens lui
glace le sang vous avez bien compris
georges leclercq l'ancien dirigeant de
la congrégation de mont-laurier ce
georges leclercq aurait perdu son titre
d'ancien et ses privilèges de témoins de
jéhovah pour cause de pédophilie
[Musique]
nous avons parlé à trois femmes qui ont
porté plainte contre lui aux témoins de
jéhovah
ils nous ont raconté leur histoire mais
ont refusé de le faire devant la caméra
comment vous avez réagi quand aiguillon
confirmé c'est ce que j'ai trouvé le
père je pense depuis au moins 20 ans
tout incident d'abus d'enfants rapporté
al interne chez les témoins doit être
envoyées au quartier général de chaque
pays
aux etats unis l'accès à cette liste de
pédophile fait l'objet d'une bataille
épique entre les avocats des victimes et
ceux des témoins de jéhovah la lettre de
pénélope michel courtemanche l'a reçu
lui aussi en 2014 ils téléphonent aux
parents de pénélope et finit par se
mettre à table bay a avoué avoir
beaucoup beaucoup de choses et avoue que
c'est lui qui menait me rejoigne il ya
voué à ma mère qui avait eu ni son pénis
dans la bouche mais vous voulez avoué le
viol mais est ce que michel courtemanche
vous appelez vous jamais nous avons
rejoint michel courtemanche au téléphone
il a refusé de nous rencontrer et a tout
nié en bloc
il nous a affirmé avoir commis une
erreur celle de s'être retrouvé seul
avec pénélope à toutes les autres
questions sur des gestes sexuels commis
sur une mineure
il a déclaré ceci dit
jacques michel courtemanche ne fait plus
partie des témoins de jéhovah
il a été exclu il y a trois ans à la
suite de la lettre de pénélope et de la
dénonciation de deux autres femmes
[Musique]
certaines choses ont changé depuis cette
époque aujourd'hui les témoins de
jéhovah affirme avertir certains parents
de la présence d'un pédophile notoire
dans leur congrégation
ce n'est pas suffisant croix carole
poudrier mon frère qui est ancien je
demandais à mon frère je dis si des
enfants qui sont victimes de pédophilie
dans votre congrégation qu'est ce que
vous faites ce que vous faites de disco
pour leur dire personne le droit de vous
toucher ce que vous faites est
maintenant le changement chez les
témoins de jéhovah pénélope n'y croit
plus sa quête de justice se poursuivra
ailleurs elle vient de déposer une
nouvelle plainte à la police
la sûreté du québec de mont laurier a
rouvert l'enquète qui prend de l'ampleur
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ou demain on lance pas on
est à près d'une quarantaine de
personnes qui ont été rencontrés
oui des témoins mais également des
victimes on est en mesure d'établir qui
pourrait y avoir sept victimes
potentielles dont quatre ont
officiellement porté plainte contre
michel courtemanche ou georges leclercq
et les enquêteurs de la sûreté tendent
l'oreille on cherche à identifier
d'autres victimes potentielles qui se
sentent peut-être seul pas prête à
parler ils doivent savoir que les
enquêteurs sont prêts à les rencontrer
également des témoins bien que les gens
c'est sûr qu'ils connaissent des choses
pour pénélope c'était la dernière étape
je suis content je suis vraiment
contente si je vois au moins qu'il ya
des gens qui m'écoutent
enfin que j'avais raison puis si ça va
nulle part mais j'aurai fait mon but
on